Okay.
So what am I doing now?
Well, I should probably tweet, shouldn't I?
My plan is to play with cluster API
a little bit more.
And passed some new changes to the cluster
API, which should allow me to upgrade my
Kubernetes
cluster.
Let me just get this tweet out.
So there was a there was an issue
with the
packet now Equinix metal cluster API provider.
And
let me just show you the pull request
I submitted yesterday.
What you'll see is when we actually provision
the cluster,
we were just installing the latest version of
the Kubelet and Kubelet m.
What that means is even if you request
an earlier version of Kubernetes,
you are never gonna get it. You would
always always always get the latest and greatest
version of Kubernetes.
And
I wanted to to do some content on
the cluster API provider
to show how cool the cluster API is
for doing upgrades of clusters as well.
So what I wanna do is just test
this pull request. Now this pull request was
actually merged
yesterday.
And I had left a comment on it
saying, hey, I haven't done the test for
this shit.
And someone very nicely merged anyway. Now what
I can confirm is that the commands here
do pull the latest version or do pull
the specific version using the app cache on
Debian and Ubuntu
to
actually work. But it hasn't been tested end
to end, and I'm gonna do that now.
To do so, I'm gonna run through the
quick start just following the really basic instructions
of cluster API.
And then we will
we will try and spin up Kubernetes
one eighteen cluster
and upgrade it to one nineteen.
Okay. So I just need to prepare a
few things.
Now, what I would suggest is if you're
watching
and, you know, have questions, drop them in
the chat.
I always like a confirmation that my audio
is actually working. So, you know, I would
appreciate a thumbs up from someone.
So the amount of times I started streaming
and I just not had things working,
it's all too common.
So let's grab
my
credentials that I need.
So you all seen.
Awesome.
I have my API token.
And let's store that in a fail.
Hold on. Let me drag item over here
for a second.
Pack it.
And my code over,
save the file, close it, and drag it
all back.
Secure as can be.
Okay.
Oh, yeah. I need to actually do one
more thing, don't I? So hold on.
This requires
me to actually export at the desk, not
just store it in a file.
So
k.
I took in.
Alright.
And when I resize that window, it's gonna
show my token again.
Let's fill it up with some random text.
Okay.
Perfect.
And let's not confuse myself. Right.
So now I'm gonna use Docker
for Mac as my management cluster and keep
this really, really simple,
which means if I do get nodes,
this is Docker desktop. Right? Nothing fancy here.
I am going to install the cluster API
controller
with the packet provisioner.
My exposed environment variable,
and That that should be all it takes
really to get started. Once we've got the
cluster API controller working, which we can get
let go of the background, we we just
need to generate a cluster API configuration.
And to do that, we just need to
expose a few environment variables to tell it,
you know, what size the node should be,
etcetera.
Oh, I'm still in this view. Probably makes
a bit more sense if I'm on
this view.
Yeah. Yeah. That's better. See?
Cool. So let's call this
the comments.
Alright. So
what do we wanna do? Where is my
SSH key? It's called m b p sixteen.
That will do.
I'm using SE key, which uses the secure
enclave on a Mac. It's pretty sweet.
Let's go with AMS one.
It's my project ID.
Let's switch organization.
Better.
And my project ID.
Alright. Now, pod side or service side, I'm
gonna run them as a default. Those work
well with packet because it doesn't use our
10 dot x
either. And I'm
I'm not sure if the t one smalls
will be available in my region.
I'll quickly do a recheck.
We may wanna go with something a bit
beefier anyway just for the lulls.
Let's go with a c three medium.
X 86.
Cool.
We'll call it ENV.
Don't know why that didn't save to this
directory. No big deal.
So what does it want me to do
next? It wants me to generate a copy
configuration.
Now the way that the changes I've made
to the cluster API work is
it uses app cache policy kubelet
to search app cache for a version. Now
the way that this works is it's actually
gonna do a pretty much a pattern match.
So I don't need to be as specific
as this example is here,
which is actually quite nice.
So if I paste that in,
what I should be able to do is
actually just specify
oh, no. Well, Capi may not let me
away with that, will it?
Let's try just go with one eighteen
to
you know what? Let's see. Let's see what
Kathy says if I take it off.
Oh, yeah. And I have to source. This
is gonna fail. So let's just echo this
out.
I
need to source
my ENV file, but if I save it
to the wrong directory,
it should give me access to project ID.
What was it called?
Oh, it doesn't let's just try
I'm type today.
Echo
project.
Okay. That's better.
We pull back this, take off the echo.
And invalid. What's the full semantic?
That's disappointing.
The script would have supported a much looser
representation.
See if we can get a one eight
one eighteen dot two out of this.
Failed to identify
the default infrastructure
provider.
Yeah.
I did run cluster CTO. Did it fail?
And I just wasn't paying attention.
But that's not running. I don't even remember
that.
Packet API key.
Did I export that wrong? Let me check.
It did. I did pack the API token.
Were the docs wrong or is I wrong?
So it's back.
API in it. That should work. What does
the docs say?
Unless, when the docs are right, and I
wish it's been a bit silly.
Yeah.
Oh, well.
So that's gonna install cert manager into our
cluster
and then the cluster API controllers.
Then I'll be able to generate our CAPI
config. Hopefully, it's been up a cluster. I'm
hoping it works. Like it says, this hasn't
actually been tested end to end.
But the PR is merged, so now is
a good time as any to test it.
Right?
So we're generating a configuration for Kubernetes one
eighteen point two.
Nice. And I should just be able to
apply this
to Docker for Mac.
Awesome. Now you can now run
get cluster API.
And it looks good.
Now I need to wait.
What can I do in the meantime?
Let's go take a look at the
Equinix and metal
new portal.
Yeah. Let's do that.
So
pop out this tab.
I already have a couple of clusters here.
Yeah. But there we go. Let's just fill
in this one copy.
So it's now sparing up our first control
plane node. And if I already actually got
an IP address, so maybe we could just
follow this along as it goes through its
bootstrapping process.
Let's see.
It should
maybe just not quite ready for SSH yet.
Oh, yeah. Well, we actually can follow along
with the provisioning of the machine too. Yeah.
So let's get it out of network and
write in some config.
But it's not actually even installed the operating
system yet. So there's no way MSSH should
answer that just yet.
Obviously, we
went under a a bit of a rebrand
recently.
The newpacket.com
homepage refer Equinix metal logo.
And it's got some information here, you know,
Equinix purchase packet in March.
The rebrand is only a few days old.
This happened this week. And we're now Equinix
Metal, which I love as a name. So,
you know,
I'm gonna be spatting out metal band puns
for the rest of the the rest of
the year.
And we can go to metal.equinix.com,
and this is the new corporate site.
Pretty. I like it.
Nice and fresh, clean.
As far as the portal, you know, it's
pretty much the same as the old packet
portal. But I mean, it is. It's just
been styled to reflect the new Equinix mail
branding.
The new cool thing that we've got, I'll
start doing a few streams on pretty soon.
This ability to request a new interconnect using
Equinix Fabric.
It gives us the ability to actually have
a fiber backbone into other cloud providers.
So you can run bare metal on Equinix
metal
and have really low latency connection to AWS
or to GCP.
Or as long as we are in
as long as one of these regions are
supported. So definitely something I wanna be playing
with really soon.
Let's get our copy filter back on. Where
are we on the provision?
Alright. Cool. We're just waiting for the device
to phone home now,
which only takes a moment. So, I mean,
that was pretty fast. That provision started at
03:29.
And by 03:31, it was rebooting the server.
That's pretty sweet.
And I'll probably just SSH into this device
once it does come online
and follow along with the
the cloud and logs.
And I'm hoping
that we get a successful cluster and I
haven't broken our packet provider
because that would be sad.
Sad. Sad. Sad.
My plan was actually to write a test
today.
I should have I should have submitted that
as a draft.
This PR
no. Where is it? Oh, yeah. I need
to provide test for this, but
people thought it looked good,
which is nice.
And it is relatively trivial.
I mean, it should work.
What will cause it to fail?
I take the v off, which is good.
I escape the dot. Yeah. This is not
gonna fail. I am pretty confident.
The last time I said that, you know
oops.
Machine's still rebooting.
Oh, wrong one.
Need to create a wee game or something
to play while I'm doing it for these
these components.
Or just be really impatient and keep having
the port until eventually it lets me in.
Either works.
K. Let's scan that.
Nice. We're
definitely ahead of provisioning. Oh, we're not oh,
abort.
Wow. Q Qubit's already in.
We got one nineteen too.
It's debugging time.
What went wrong?
Okay. What have we got access to? Let's
take a look at our cloud and output.
And there's the app cache. No. It's not
there.
I
haven't upgraded cluster CTL locally.
Dreads.
Let's spin up on more cluster.
So what do I need to do then
to make this work?
I need to compile cluster CTL manually.
I'm not actually sure
how
it gets the packet provider.
I've never done this before.
So when I do
cluster CTL
in it
and I specify the packet provider, I wonder
how it actually delivers that to the cluster.
I wonder
if I can just do this manually
rather than compiling things together.
I'm in a completely uncharted territory right now.
So
in fact, I know what I can do.
When I so
this is gonna get into what's actually happening
then. So when I run cluster CTL config,
webinar
it's just
boop.
So when I run cluster CTL config, it's
it's actually
generating
the provisioning scripts for me.
So let's just pop that open.
And I can just modify this with my
changes. I I don't need to recompile copy
or anything like that. In fact, I should
have remembered to do this anyway. That would've
been smart.
And you can see this is using the
old one. This has not got our new
commands in it.
So let's just go to my PR
and still look good.
This account is stealing of its main not
main contributor now.
No. Of course not. Alright. Let's grab
command number one.
B and I don't have guests. I just
talk to myself and I'm
sorry.
Alright. So let's save that. And then we
need to pin them.
This is the right one.
Yeah. It looks good.
That says updated.
Which which template is this?
That's a control plane template.
So we just need to
do the same. I'm pretty sure it's the
exact same.
And it's for the work or not.
And then we can just scroll down
here.
Upside it? Oh, we've got some format measures.
Oh, that's good.
Let me make sure I don't have those
format measures here.
Yeah. Very good. Okay. So now I could
just actually reapply this.
I think what I'll do is
delete that f
that way
and reapply
it. And I'm not sure
how long I kinda need to wait for
that.
Yeah. So it's kinda going through some sort
of deletion and reprovisioning. I wonder if I
can just tweak a few names.
Yeah.
Pro plan.
Oh, no. Because they're everywhere.
I'm just patient.
No.
Let's see.
Be patient or search and replace. Be patient
or search and replace.
18 instances.
Let's call it copy slow start.
And then we can apply this over the
top.
I'm just gonna hope I haven't broken anything
with that
very wide scoped.
So I shouldn't replace.
Should be alright.
So yep. Slow start slow start. No. We
just need to wait again until I get
a new control plane node. It spins up,
and I jump back on it and check
the cubelet version.
But at least it now has my changes.
That was that was naive of me. I
don't know why I didn't think to check
that.
Mhmm.
Well, we pop over to our thing here.
This is still quick start.
And we have slow start starting.
My is awake.
There you go.
Yeah. He can all talk to Zelda for
a minute.
Hello?
That was a fret of sneezing if you
heard that.
Yeah.
You've not had a wee snuggle today yet,
have you?
It's getting to winter. It means that she
sleeps for pretty much the majority of the
day.
Goes a rewintered coat.
Right.
Okay. Let's see. Where are we? Oh, wrong
button.
Magic install system.
Let's just
get prepared,
get impatient,
and wait.
Now the reason of that, let's go over
that too. Let's try and fill some silence.
I do have other machine. I have another
cluster in this project, actually.
Let's jump onto that machine, and I'll just
show you what these commands are doing.
But it's actually quite tricky
in Debian and Ubuntu to get
specific packages because of the
the Kubernetes version is semantically version, but then
Debbie and add on their own package version
to the end of it. So it's not
like you can just do apt
get install kubelet one eighteen two. There's then
this extra version on top of that, which
makes it just a little bit more painful
to work out.
So if we take those commands, I'll filter
this back down so we can keep an
eye on our our slow start control plan.
And let's just run this first command, and
I'll run it without the assignment for now.
So
so the Kubernetes version is passed in by
cluster API.
So
right now, that shouldn't really do anything
We can just export that ourselves
and set this to the value that I
set on the command line, which is Kubernetes
one eighteen two.
And then run this again, and we get
a trim version and an escaped version so
that we can actually use and consume that
version and save up an off script or
it's an off command in this case. So
you can see I've taken off the v
and I'm just escaping the dots because we
actually do like a reject search.
And then I assign that to a variable
called trimmed Kubernetes version.
I mean, this is overly complicated. It shouldn't
it shouldn't have to be like this, but
it's unfortunate.
We then search the app cache, and then
we're trying to filter this down. So let's
go through this one step at a time.
Right?
If I just do
an app cache policy for Kubelet, it's gonna
list every single version that is available inside
the repository.
And we get it in a slightly weird
format. And you can see
here
with one six five, we then got dash
o one and dash o o. And that's
the the Debbie and then the Ubuntu version
of the package. So there you go. They
have an incremental counter for all the changes
that they make for the package,
Which means that we then just need to
tweak this a little bit. So then
what I'm actually doing is using ARC
here
where
we're first
setting a variable in ARC.
We have to give it access to the
churn version and rather than it being trimmed
version equals trimmed version, I'm just inversion equals
trimmed version, trying to remove as much verbose
as possible.
ARC scripts are comprised of filters and commands,
And that's what's in the quote here. Our
filter is
we wanna check whether
using rejects, which is what the total operator
means. Parameter one, which is this here,
matches the version that we're passionate, which it
should with those escape dots in the version.
And then we just print it out.
Well, I should see here.
That's one eighteen two.
Let's try just tweaking
trimmed
Kubernetes
version
equals
let's do one
five
two.
It didn't use my exported one.
Export
Kubernetes
version.
I just wanna show the multiple results.
So this will be B152.
Echo Kubernetes version, they got B152.
We can then run our trimmed assignment again.
Echo trimmed.
We get our escaped minus the b,
and I'll run I'll just run this in
a whole this time. You'll see that I
also add on the head dash n one,
and that's just so that we get one
version back. But I could tweak that command
to show you the multiple results. So if
I had resolved Kubernetes version, we actually get
a note it been to a Debian package
version number we can work with.
If I run at cache here,
take off the head,
let's see that we actually get
every package version.
And they're coming back and
the correct order descending from when they were
released. So just by using the head and
one, we can always get the latest version.
Okay.
Let's drop off this machine now
and see if this one is alive.
And the moment of truth is running Qubelet
version.
It's not installed yet. Now that's
potentially a bad thing.
It could mean that our provisioning script failed
or it could still be running, but
it finished. It failed. Drats.
Alright. Let's see what went wrong.
Oh, no.
That's imputing.
Let's fix it. Okay.
So the
looks like
there's an equivalent
colon
for kubelet was not found.
Something particularly strange
happened.
So what am I gonna have to do?
Do I have access to I don't have
access to the
the user data here.
We can curl it
from metadata.packet.net
user data.
Yep.
And
store it in my root directory as user
data.
So this is cloud config syntax.
Let's get down to here. I'm trying to
work out
what hasn't worked. I'm just gonna run these
commands manually, which means I'm gonna
I'm gonna show.
So I'm gonna assume everything to this stage
will work,
which means these commands, I did just run
on another machine and worked.
Potentially, something went wrong here.
So this is our do
we have
there we go.
That's frustrating.
So it's
not
my initial thought there was, oh, crap. The
version of Valk is different, but it's not.
It's
that's escape.
That's gonna be a bit of a pain
in the ass to fix.
I'm gonna provision this manually
just
to make sure it works.
Is my result Kubernetes
wrong?
Oh, it's still wrong.
Do I have a trimmed?
Oh, right. Why did the trimmed not work?
I don't oh, yeah. Because the Kubernetes config
isn't available at this moment because I'm not
within
the cloud config.
So
that's the Kubernetes
version
b one eighteen
two.
Let's
set the trend.
Set resolved.
Now it's now resolved to the correct package.
So let's paste that on our app, get
install command again.
That works.
Silver lining,
at least.
Now, let's try and work out how we
fix
this and I
yeah. I don't know yet.
Let's see.
Yeah. You saw the version there. That was
great.
Okay.
Now can I double escape the
yeah? Let's let's try it manually first.
This is oh, that's the next. Okay. So
problem is
it's gonna skip this for me.
And my thoughts are
that's not gonna work. I thought
because we're in a situation where we have
this.
Let's check our generated config.
There are no quotes here. Those are being
added
because we have them here.
So, really,
I wonder if I can just do that
without the double quotes.
Let's try that.
Yeah. So
make sure that still works.
I'm not passing it anything there.
Just from the whole command.
This one.
And take the course
off.
Maybe there's gonna be superfluous.
That would make things a lot simpler rather
than me trying to work out how to
wrangle this
some other way.
So that didn't work.
Okay. Let's put the double quotes back in.
And we can't use single quotes because we
have
bash interpolation happening.
Well, that didn't occur anything either.
Let's try.
But we still have trimmed.
Using myself now.
Let's take off the head.
I just have cash policy.
There's an equal, there's a match.
What's this?
It's not escaped. Should it be escaped by
now?
Yes.
Okay. Let's try again.
Terms
looks good.
I'm cash policy keep
have I have I have I broken my
alt command?
What have I done?
It should move the filler just now.
Yeah. I like that.
Version.
Excuse me.
That's not correct.
The version
should
be
our trimmed Kubernetes version.
Instead,
we're getting something different.
Let's
we run this. So we should have a
Kubernetes version.
I got a trim version,
unless they are resolved version.
A blank. Okay. Everything
is fucked.
So
I'm sure
I'm being silly,
and I just
can't
spot it yet.
Let's build this back from the ground up.
Hey. We get what we want with the
policy command.
I want to go through I wanna assign
a variable
Version equals trend.
Kubernetes
version.
Let's not do the filler just now. Let's
just
print our version.
Let me close off this.
That's interesting.
Yeah. That's not working at all.
Riddle me this.
Let's change the assignment
here.
E m.
Okay.
So
Alright. For the defined variables, you just don't
use the dollar syntax.
And it came to me in a moment
of clarity there that that's only really for
things that are inside of it.
As that are
matched in the after the filter.
So that means that my version line was
actually key.
Add our filter back in.
Because the command, the default is just to
print everything.
Still not matching.
Yeah. I anymore version.
Looks alright.
We have a one eighteen too.
I'm just gonna have to start verifying everything.
I'm losing the main tier.
Okay.
Alright. Let's try this again.
And one, that's what we're doing to match
against.
That's fine.
So
on
version.
I see an as the regex here, then
print it.
Nothing.
Can't
believe I'm fading
with Rawk.
Am I getting I mean, I don't I'm
not getting that command wrong. I know that
command.
Let's revalidate
this input. Something is clearly
not working.
I should print one.
Good.
Add a really simple filler.
Oh.
Oh, that shouldn't matter. Right?
It doesn't matter.
The two works.
works.
One
eighteen.
The variable would be fine.
Okay.
We are actually passing on two, so let's
just for the sake of completeness.
Oh.
There is no one eighteen to
or something I'm doing
because it already installed.
Okay. That
was painful.
Alright. So what what I need to do
is
confirm the dash the the variable assignment is
gonna work.
Let's say double quote, so we should be
alright.
So
let's do maybe
equals
18. I might just go with three to
avoid
a weird thing.
And we wanna confirm that
we can use
IP
and that
isn't working just yet because
this isn't the thing
with an Elm script.
Oh,
we do the dash b here.
And
if I can just get away,
things will work.
And just so we don't have a duplication
of name, let's just do this.
Make sure we get the right value.
Right.
That was painful.
So the problem was
these quotes are superfluous,
but they did break because they were being
escaped and failing the matter to work.
And
we can just remove them from here too.
Sweet.
Because I've now got my
let's see. Let's change Kubernetes version so that
will work. Oh, no. Then the trend one
will be wrong.
Set trend.
Close.
11183.
Perfect.
Cool.
I've updated this file,
and then I need to spend a new
cluster.
Let's
kill slow start and go to fast start.
And I'm gonna apply.
I will under that change just so I
can delete.
We'll start.
Bye.
We go there.
Unfortunately,
it doesn't mean that I need to update
this poor request. Poor guy's is merged. I
need to update the repository.
Let's do that just now.
Packet host.
Oh, no.
Kubernetes saved cluster API for later.
Master
changes.
And this is
a fix.
Remove
superfluous
quotes.
See if I can get that pushed through
by a few colleagues.
One more.
That's why things should be tested.
First,
Lewis quotes that breaks semantic
versioning
matcher.
This is my branch.
And open on your pull request.
What's in this
command
are escaped.
I cleared in it causing the
rejects
matcher to fail
and all version of the kubelet,
kubedm,
and
ship c t l
are installed.
Cool.
It's good.
So let's pop over to here.
Refresh
on this.
Copy.
I start it there. I'm not sure why
these two haven't disappeared yet.
Let's just say
gives them a gentle nudge.
Got an IP address here. Although, I'm gonna
assume it's
prob
there you go. Yeah. I probably still oh,
no. It's not too early. Alright. Let's I'll
phone it home in a second.
Come on this machine.
Well, fifty two minutes to
cool.
Couplet.
Not yet.
I'd close and it finished. Is it still
broking?
Right.
I see the fast start box.
Oh, that's right. Yeah.
We've done a metadata.
And
I just
I did update both of those quotes. Right?
Yes.
Yeah. That's it.
Done here.
Yep.
K. Let's try to see if that machine
is responding.
Let's pull down the metadata.
The user data. Sorry.
I mean,
I'm pretty happy with that.
So that's interesting.
Let's see if it's fail.
This
no Kubernetes version here.
So why is that not being interpolated?
We have another
problem.
I grabbed that as an example from something
else that I saw being posted in.
But I may have made that up.
Looks like I did.
So
let's look for this.
Let's see. I know the variables are mentioned.
Shit.
Alright. Let's fix that. Now, if we take
a look at what's actually in the user
data, there is some interpolation.
We can see the control plane endpoint
is passed in.
Actually, it's in the ghost style templates.
We're gonna try and fudge that then.
Let's go take a look at the copy
code. Have
have no idea what I'm doing at the
moment.
That is copy.
Check up the fader stuff first.
Let's do a somewhere in logged in.
Let's work in progress this.
How do I do that again?
Oh, wait. That's still
Jason, you're too quick.
Shit. Alright. Let's try and fix this then.
I wonder if he's available. Let's just ping
him.
I sent him a message on Slack. Maybe
he can speed this process up and tell
me how that interpolation is actually happening into
those files.
Cool. Alright.
He says he'll be available soon.
In the meantime,
I will be back.
Oh, we've got some go templates here
for plain endpoint.
See if we can find
so this is our template.
Let's search for that.
You can see the call to go template.
To not die.
It looks like this defines a Kubernetes version.
I just need to work out how to
get that into the provision or the cloud
in it data.
Let's try
template.
Yeah. That's quite a lot of templates, actually.
This is probably what I want.
Feels right.
I can see the special handler for the
control plan endpoint.
Let's
let's think.
This is creating a new device.
It was a control plane.
Parses the user data.
Yeah. That's okay. This is the right bit.
And the API key has been injected. Let's
see if we can see that.
Oh.
Punching
my mic now.
Jason is typing.
That's good.
This template execute.
So the API key struck. I think that's
maybe just poorly named.
It was really just a variable map.
I could add
a Kubernetes version to that.
How confident do I feel?
Alright. Fuck it. Let's do it. Okay. So
we need to inject the version.
We'll come back here.
And the branch has been merged.
Cool.
Offered Jason
to some private if he doesn't wanna stream
Cisco.
Let me drop off, but we'll see.
Let's get a new branch.
It's again.
Inject
Kubernetes
version.
Cool. Join them. And Jason will join us
on the stream.
Client.co.
Let's get it ready to show them. In
fact, I can just send them the link.
Sweet.
And assist.
I'm
I'm trying to be sure what I need.
Something here.
And it's not gonna be an f. It's
just gonna be an always. There's always gonna
be a version provided.
It close.
And I'll just wait for someone who knows
what the hell they're doing.
Hello?
Hello.
Hi.
So I got myself in a pickle.
Assume I should give you a little bit
of context first.
Alright.
So I submitted a PR yesterday
and just said there was no test yet,
but it's miraculous to make its way into
the master branch. So I thought I better
test this, and I figured I would stream
it. It would all work and nothing would
go wrong.
And the first problem I ran until you've
already merged, so thank you. Then close it
because
the YAML is loaded and and
encapsulated with the courts. The courts have said
to escape, and then the match on the
arc was failing. So we're past that. The
problem is
I was miraculously
expecting the Kubernetes version
be able to exist.
Oh, sorry. That that doesn't exist? No. I
think I found where to inject it, which
is API construct,
which seems to happen,
which I think is gonna pass at the
template
execute.
Does that seem right?
Yeah. That seems right.
Generally, if somebody was doing this with
following the upstream docs,
that's one of the variables that's passed into
the templates when you call
the cluster cuddle command to
create the cluster resources from templates.
Okay. So if I just made a mistake
and it's not a problem then?
So sorry. Let me confirm what I think
you were saying there.
I'll go back to my directory
here.
So if I
to the command that I ran
Yep. After the Kubernetes version here
Yep.
And you're saying that the output YAML
should have
API key. I better delete that now.
Yeah. I I created it here. Okay.
Yeah. Basically, that command line argument for
cluster cuddle config cluster
basically just,
you know, interpolates the Kubernetes
version environment variable.
Oh, okay. So I am in a peck
of it as well. That's what that is
my fault. So it's the reason
I
I modified this after generating it because I
don't I don't wanna have to build cluster
CTL control cuddle
myself.
So I should just do that and confirm
that this still works. Right? Yeah. And it
should just be a matter of
running ENV substitute.
I don't think there's anything too advanced that
would be replaced that you couldn't just do
with ENV substitute.
Right. Okay.
So the Kubernetes all uppercase underscore version is
fine, and I'm just stressing over nothing.
Hopefully.
Cool.
Alright.
Well, I built this now, so let's just
okay.
Oh, no. Because yeah. There is this is,
like, the first three minutes of the stream,
had this question.
How do when I run cluster control and
a provider packet,
do I need to do anything to get
it to use this version? Like, how how
do they correlate?
The version of Kubernetes and the version of
the packet provider?
Yeah. So when I run cluster control provider,
I don't get the new templates that were
merged. Is there another step that has to
happen there?
Yes.
In the cluster API
documentation
that's generated and published to Netlify, that has
kind of
a a set of steps that you can
run to basically use the developer workflow and
use a locally,
checked out copy of the provider.
You would have to follow those steps in
order to be able to run the local
changes. Otherwise, it's just going to pull the
latest
published release that's out there.
Okay.
So it should be under
cluster cuddle.
There's a section.
Cluster cuddle for developers there, 2.4.
Alright. Using most local artifacts.
Sweet.
So I create this JSON file, and that's
it.
Yeah. That that's just gonna tell cluster cuddle
when you run it to override the defaults
that it
that it has internally or or it looks
up
from GitHub.
Okay.
I'm just trying to work out whether I
need to create that file and that's particular
location or not.
It seems that I think this is assuming
I may be in a a local clone
of
that repo.
So let's see.
Yeah. That's gonna be the local
copy of the repo.
Let me see.
You may actually want the
yeah. I think there's some that you can
override with just the cluster cuddle config. Yeah.
I'm all there. Let me see if I
can look it up.
I mean, I guess I could always just
hope that the variable is there. I guess
I
I I wouldn't expect it to be unless
we publish the new
version of
the packet provider since
since those changes got merged.
Oh, what I mean is, like, this Kubernetes
version variable will be interpolated and
low. Right? Yeah. That you're pretty confident that
where is it?
Oh, yeah. That's the one I generated.
Yeah. I mean, you you said you're pretty
confident that that is when I run cluster
configs, that's just gonna work anyway. Right? Yes.
That should. Yeah. Okay.
Then I fixed the quotes. Maybe I should
just be confident. So, like,
if I want to test this with so
any local modifications on my side
is
Does that just mean that we need to
tag a release on the packet side? Or
yeah. Okay. Yeah. Yeah.
Basically, what cluster cuddle does is it looks
at the
you know, it's configured to
where the GitHub repository is for the various
providers, and it looks at the latest published
release that's not a prerelease.
Okay.
I guess I can just wait for the
release.
Or at least I can try playing around
with this later.
Alright. I'm confident. I think it's gonna work.
It's been a trying hour and a half.
So my plan was to spin up a
one eighteen two cluster and then do an
upgrade, and I kinda go down this rabbit
hole of
trying to use the new configuration without the
manual modifications.
So I I I mean, I can just
do that myself. Right? So if I just
search and replace Kubernetes,
I'm not gonna be able to search and
replace.
Alright. And if I just be a bit
more specific.
And this will be one
eighteen.
And I don't need you anymore because I
was gonna start doing that. That's gonna be
a bad thing.
And I'm now on to my third name
of this cluster. I've had quick start, slow
start, fast start, and then I'm gonna do
right start.
So that I don't have to wait on
everything disappearing.
Alright.
Alright. Thank
you for your help. You're more than welcome
to just hang around while I spin this
up and kick the tires on it, but
I don't expect you to take time out
of your day to sit and watch this.
I have I have some other stuff I
have to look at, some reviews I'm kinda
backlogged on. But if you do hit any
issues, let me know, and I'll be happy
to rejoin. Thank you very much. I really
appreciate that. That was helpful. Yep. I'll speak
to you soon. Alright.
It's good to get help then again.
Hey. Right. Start. No. I'm not gonna do
the upgrade
as it is getting a little bit late.
What I will do is confirm that one
eighteen two installs.
And then next week, I will run an
upgrade.
So I'll wait for the IP address, the
machine to reboot, jump on it, and hope
for the best.
We have an IP address, which is good.
We can kill faster.
And push
here.
Search restatins of that nine. Let take that
like that.
And we're wet.
Looks a bit dark on there. Let's see
if I can get my lights up.
Gives me something to do for a few
minutes.
Woah.
I'm bright.
Few minutes, few seconds, whatever.
And I need to delete that API token
that I shared with everybody.
That was fun.
Let's just pop this open
in a new window
and
delete.
Done.
I
should bring a book to read
during these moments.
But slower this time.
We need to play with some buttons.
I quite like that one, but it's a
bit small.
We could if you could make it just
a little bit bigger.
Let's do this.
Looks good.
We got a little clash on the keys.
New lane expected.
Fuck you.
And what the user data?
And
that it that's nothing to do with me.
I hope that's not it.
There's a new line.
I don't feel
like that's my problem.
That seems to run the oh,
that's my problem.
Where'd that come from?
Strats.
Alright.
Great start.
Final start.
And I'll have final two start and I'm
done.
Alright. One more time.
Delete.
That's making sure.
The API key is missing. That's not gonna
work.
Create a livestream key that can be a
little bit more expandable
than the one I've been using and then
delete it.
Nothing's gonna
no wrong start will spin up here.
Export.
We're
CTL edit.
And I need to reset the Docker daemon,
the Kubernetes daemon.
And then reprovision
the cluster controller
with the new seeker. I could probably have
started
editing things and restarting controllers,
you know, resetting a Kubernetes cluster with Docker
for Mac doesn't exactly take long.
And I already feel like I'm committed now.
See.
I'll resend that updated my config. That's good.
I'm tired now. This is stressful work.
Come on, Docker Kubernetes.
Let's just see if I've got access to
my control plan.
Right. Okay.
So let's bring this back. Now the secret
bit is done.
My key is there. I'm deleting that in
a minute anyway.
I'm beyond kidding now. So
and
which year.
Reprovision
cluster CTL,
reapply
manifest.
See what happens.
And then I am done. It's too late
and afraid for this shit.
I have a comment.
Watching a stream about upgrades, my virtual machine
just died. Yep.
All of my shit is dying. Like,
I don't know if you've been watching for
five minutes or the whole hour and a
half, but it's not going well.
But it's been fun. I'm learning about cluster
API. So
so now that we've reprovisioned the packet provider
with my now very public Equinix metal API
key.
Just wanna reapply wrong start.
Confirm that it shows up
over here.
Moment, hopefully.
I just wanna see Kubernetes
one eighteen two on this machine, and then
I'll deal with the upgrade layer.
But we did fix the cool editor. Silver
lining. Right?
Why? Why? Why?
Let's see what's going on.
My credentials are only seventy two seconds old.
I'm hoping that's a new one.
The controllers
should be running.
And patience again, as always.
Let's hope we get a fast deploy this
time.
This machine
quick.
And I open I want you.
I love that the stream started off about
upgrades, and it's just turned into
defect hunting, bug hunting.
See.
Patience is a virtue, David.
Wait. I have the time.
Don't get you anymore.
Could probably kill the API key nervous pause.
I mean, all I wanna do is
confirm.
And I refresh refresh refresh.
Yeah. Come on, Kubernetes.
One eighteen two. One eighteen two. One eighteen
two.
I don't know. It.
Check. Done.
Keep it. Keep it.
Keep it. Keep Keep it.
That's a relief.
Good.
It worked.
So
I have two choices.
Again, gives this cluster enough time to become
healthy
and walk through the upgrade process, albeit
10 to five,
or I can say at least the changes
I've made to the packet slash Equinix mail
provider work.
And
to another stream
tackling the upgrade. What is involved in an
upgrade?
Let's
see.
So
apparently, can run an upgrade plan.
We gotta drop my connection there again. Weird.
Over here.
First CTL
upgrade.
Oh.
Fine.
Alright.
So that updates the provider. So it's not
what I want.
How do I upgrade a cluster?
Dope. Alright. Yeah. That's useless. Next.
I I saw
upgrades were a thing.
There we go.
So to upgrade the control plane machines, let's
say we start with that.
We copy the existing machine template,
modify the values,
create the new machine template,
and then update the QVDM control plane ref.
Right. Okay.
Let's go for it. Fuck it.
So
let's just do a control plane upgrade. I'm
not gonna do the work or notes. We
don't even have them yet anyway.
And it wants us to upgrade the machine
template followed by the the QVDM control plane.
Is there a machine template?
No. That's the packet machine template. We don't
want that.
Wrong one.
Search for the Qubit commands.
Qubitm config template.
I think those docs are wrong. Okay.
Yeah. This looks right. Let's
Give us a new name
as a worker. I don't know why they're
control plan. I ain't got time for
time for everything.
Scroll up. There
we go. So
Confused there. Because it does tell me to
modify the existing resource
to the new machine template and the infrastructure
ref,
which is a map which has a packet
machine template. I don't wanna change the packet
machine template. I wonder if this is something
that's just unique to a bare metal cluster.
Let's just
let's just change this.
Alright. First thing, Josh, let's see which versions
of
one nineteen are available on the app cache
policy.
One nineteen two is good.
And because we need that here,
we need to modify that.
See that a few times for good luck.
Right.
So in theory,
if I just apply this over the top,
we know how that our control plan is
reconfigured.
And I'm curious
to know what that means
here.
But now it's actually spinning up a new
control plane.
Yeah. It's still provisioning the initial workers.
I
don't know if I'm just being impatient
as I normally am.
I'm just gonna start doing that control plan
at the same time. Now the reason I
think it may wait
is because in our control plan configuration, we
we actually do have replicas of three.
And our cluster is not currently healthy.
I really I actually don't expect it to
try and spin up a or do an
upgrade of our control plane yet.
Maybe we should just get
let's get this healthy first. So
there's a command with a cluster thing from
quick start that gives us a cube config
for the cluster.
We need to do that just now.
And then
copy.
Final star.
What's our cost of gold?
Here.
Copy panel start.
Secrets.
I'll keep config.
Oh.
Right. Okay. So now I can do a
cube config
equals
copy.
Alright. Cube config get notes.
See, our customer is not actually healthy. Yeah.
We haven't deployed the c n I implementation.
So we can just use the example one
here to deploy Calico.
And if we watch that, we actually should
see if the calico pods come up on
each of those machines and the yeah. We're
already starting to turn to ready.
But actually important,
the control plan turn in ready particularly
now means that the management cluster or local
cluster API cluster
will see that and then start to spin
up the other two control plane notes.
And now we're gonna be in this really
weird situation where I've already modified the QBDM
config template for the control notes.
So, I mean, as we see a new
control plan note
showing up here,
probably gonna deploy one nineteen.
Yeah. There we go.
So I wonder if I sabotage myself already.
Well, I'm not sabotage myself, to be honest.
The control plane, one of them being upgraded
is actually fine.
I see one way to do an upgrade,
but probably not the prescribed way to do
an upgrade.
Oops.
Bear with me on calendar. Did I have
any more meetings today?
Nothing more important than this. We get right.
So
let's
put you
I won't be ready yet. Hopefully, it won't
be too long.
So
that means the next two control planes
yeah. I'm gonna spin up the one nineteen.
And I wonder
because we have the reconciliation
loop with the management cluster keeping an eye
on our control plan.
Once the other two are up,
I can probably
I I don't know if I can just
tell that machine
and it'll be replaced. I'm curious.
I mean,
I'm good in my head.
Not sure if that's what actually happens.
Because if we take a look at the
cluster API resources,
what we actually get are
machines.
How curious that if I destroy this, if
it spins up a new one,
which should be really nice in this case,
Thank you. I keep meaning to
mute myself when I cough, but sometimes I
forget. Appreciate it.
It would be quite nice. So what I'm
thinking of now, rather sort of rather than
there being an
you know, like a prescribed cluster control, upgrade
this cluster command that redeploys
a new control plane and swap them over
or something like that. So it may
be as simple as just upgrading the control
plane template, which we did, apply it to
the cluster, and then kill the machines one
by one and wait until they come back
up. Right? I mean, that's that's how I
would do an upgrade if it was not
using cluster control using the cluster API.
And I'm hoping that workflow actually just works.
What we wanna confirm now is that
it's still running. I'm sure it's not gonna
fail anymore. And I'm assuming you don't actually
hear the beep, so I'm just gonna go
to.
Alright. So keep it keep it up. One
nineteen to okay. So that's pretty cool. I
like that, actually.
So
that means
watch this. Let's wait for that second control
plane mode to become
ready.
There we go. Almost there.
And then those that it's a control plan
with the master role.
Ready yet.
And now I'm gonna lose access to the
API server
because there is an election happening between the
two nodes. The first one will take a
little while.
It will
fall over shortly.
I'm not I'm not sure why I have
noticed this a few times now when the
second control plane notice comes on, I I
lose access.
And I think we're just passing around an
elastic IP
that hasn't really settled yet.
Let's see if we got a third one
on the way.
So this is two.
Oh, okay. Almost there. So when it starts
getting refused, it's not time and out. It
means the IP has been allocated.
We're just waiting for the API server to
start saying hello to me.
Maybe. There we go.
Sweet.
That is
cool.
Now how brave do I feel? There should
be a third one now. They're both ready.
The controller is gonna try and get me
a third one up.
And then we'll see how brave I'm feeling
about breaking this loop.
I could wait for the third one to
at least start provisioning before I get
gotta hammer it.
Too impatient.
I'm just gonna delete it.
So I wanna delete this one, the one
eighteen one to see if it gets replaced
or not.
Too late to go back now.
I'm pretty sure this is the one we
deleted.
We'll wait for that delete to if that's
the new one there.
This livestream should just be called. What happens
is
I do things I'm not supposed to do.
Alright. That's definitely deleted there.
What does cluster API think of the world?
Really?
No.
So the the
hasn't
kick started anything
Ever
I mean, it remains
we are in a
a rather variable state right now with that
third control plan non being provisioned.
It could be
once that becomes ready,
it will pay attention to the missing node
and start to replace it. I would have
expected the phase to at least change now.
Although,
I'm not sure what API calls this provider
is doing behind the scene. If it's just
if it checks that it exists
anymore.
Mean, we could probably look at the code.
Maybe better if I had someone that knew
more about it rather than me flailing around
it.
So I'm just gonna delete it.
See what happens.
Well, I wonder if I should delete that
instead, or was it too late?
Yeah. To the so what I was thinking
there was rather than deleting the machine, actually
delete the concrete packet machine.
Leave that machine intact.
Because I was curious to see if the
user data is baked into this somehow,
and it would have deployed the same version.
That would give us a slightly different upgrade
path moving forward.
Well, this has got the name in it,
and I don't need to type.
Doesn't appear really to have, like, the user
data or anything there.
And it's trying to drain the node.
Obviously, not gonna work. It killed it.
Let's just create this. I wonder if it
does it notice that that machine disappeared?
No.
It doesn't appear that the packet provider
monitors the health of the machine.
I can speak to Jason about that and
see if I can get a better understanding
of what what happens at that stage.
And it's still deleting.
I'm not really sure what's happening at this
layer.
We maybe have a second control play note.
It may be doing the
the h a dance.
Really, if it's not working, say the watch,
of course.
And there's a very
good chance that I've just killed my control
plane anyway.
Very likely or it has potential.
I guess this is a good example of
how not to upgrade a cluster.
I would like to think that IP
came back, though. That wasn't IP of the
machine, was it?
Possibly.
Must be an Elastic IP. Right?
Must be.
What is that? 14710226.
Yeah. It's an elastic IP.
To control plane, no. It's
Alright. What can I do now?
Jump on both of these.
See if my
IP appears to be available.
Uh-huh. And this one.
Nope.
Yeah. My elastic IP hasn't oh, no. It
has. There we go.
We do have a control plan node with
the IP.
We're try to start it four more times.
Mine.
It
was attached to this machine. Right?
It began.
Nope.
Alright. You should be at local host.
It is.
And we do have a Qubelet running.
Maybe not for long.
Back in a moment.
There we go.
Someone at my door.
Okay. So we have a cubelet running. The
IP address is attached. It's been running for
twenty minutes.
But it's just it's it's broken. It's not
coming back.
It's done at the leading phase with the
first control plan. It's oh, it still says
the provisioning, the other one.
And maybe I'm just being too impatient, but
I don't
I don't think I am.
It's weird.
I keep switching between
time out,
connection refused.
It tells me that the IP address is
bouncing around.
Never again refused again.
API.
It's also provisioning.
Yeah.
I'm just not sure it's salvageable.
I knew
upgrading the cluster.
But so waiting for it to even really
get into a itchy healthy state was probably
a bad idea.
I'm gonna just kill all this.
And we're approaching two hours anyway, I think.
Return to this next week.
Oh, yeah. I'm empty just to save with
it.
Right. That connection refused shouldn't happen.
Speaking to the kubelet on this local host.
Let me restart this kubelet.
Might I get connection refused?
I think it only binds on the IP.
Try it from here then.
Logs.
Oh, well.
Yeah. It's failing.
I want to find the other notes.
Some sort of weird direction thing happening here
in the loop.
Filter should have known least.
Shit.
Yeah.
Definitely broken it.
I mean, it should fix itself.
I don't really know how the leases are
being managed.
Like
no. I think that the problem is probably
was just too quick to call the other
machine. Although we don't have two control play
notes that are healthy.
I'm assuming SCD hadn't completed
copy of the data to the other version.
And
I have now lost that CD. And if
you lose that CD,
there's probably not any chance we bring them
back to this cluster.
Yeah. It's just not gonna happen.
Maybe an entity on this.
Alright. I'm calling it.
Hey. Let's open Docker.
Try the world.
It's the provision.
Alright. That's unfortunate.
Next week, I will spend up a $1.18
2 cluster, which I know works.
I will probably spend it up with a
single control plane mode
and do an upgrade of that first,
then tackle the h a one.
And but I'll always spend that up in
advance so that we don't have to sit
here and listen to me ramble on to
myself while we wait for that to get
healthy, get impatient, and destroy the entire cluster
again.
And we'll go through the various upgrade paths
as well,
and
it'll be much better.
Thanks for watching.
Have a great weekend.
I'll see you all soon.